[Music]
actually at the time I was a big Chelsea
fan when Didier Drogba was there and I
know you were dad I think your first
game you subbed in for
Turia's right that was your first day
that was your baby was just right yeah
yeah yeah yeah I guess it was crazy it
was crazy at that time and I was 18 I
just you know finished high school three
months before that graduated from high
school you were like yeah I'm here
that's the big weeks my Fuhrer game for
me yeah
did I mean my first game I had like 27
points I hit like seven threes
and yeah I mean did not realize like
after the game we got like eighty one
more game so it kind of good about this
one everything happened like I was on
the three goats in London and I remember
meeting a de you know he was happening
like it was on the like on the with the
teacher therapist working on his anchor
for whatever and I went to him and you
know I was like oh you need to but you
need to show me the blue paper right now
oh and I held him and I was like you
need to do this right now
and like we spoke for everyday like for
now before practice after practice and
then like him and Anelka and all and
every every player that Locker will show
me like what it took to become Who I am
today you know what I mean like the work
ethic like that team was like okay it
was not really like the coach he was the
players they had that mentality of like
okay let's go with and poem and I would
see it on the sidelines I was like okay
this is how it's gonna be I know dollar
let's go so it was a good experience for
me just being 18 being around those
tools and and and seeing you know seeing
how they wanted to have to seek the
época
how they prepared for it for me to
witness all of that you know are now
coming in my life my pride years you
know this is something that I'm taking
you for the rest of them whatever so
it's your favorite sneakers your your
offer your favorite sneakers in your
collection
um right now probably the bread Elevens
yeah when they came out really good
bread 11
I got like yeah everyone is your mom
whenever they give you I switch to
another class got any of those you open
those knocking open up I feel like I'll
switch my annoying
we're walking that was for me like EMT
code difficult thing in the World Cup
like when we lost against France at the
time I didn't realize you know I was
still numb you know you know I was still
in a in a in an unplowed like little bit
of a call now because we get we were to
the semi-finals and stuff you know we're
a small country only 11 million people
but the painting one month later when I
was like watching all the videos of the
World Cup and stuff like that and he
brought me to this dog spot bro alive it
was difficult that year was really
difficult because I was like you we were
that close and he just hit me after you
know what I mean that was bad though but
it is what it is yeah that's why yeah
yeah and that's why this year when I
went to inter like I had like all the
anchors it just build up inside of me
and I was like your man on the mission
but this is me like let's go and then
who would you say is the biggest super
head on the Hornet squad biggest [ __ ]
head
yeah would you like to name yourself huh
we we have a lot of guys that sign with
George
my Chico for me so Cody Zeller biz
Hawaiian bacon
Devante and both the twins they all
sound like doing so they can pretty much
get all the shoes every time they gonna
have all the Queenie's everything that
comes out to get it I really don't care
I was an hour's legit like I would say
like you know players that played
against me in the kids categories they
knows I was a cheat code when I was
checked I was putting like check out
that man I was run with the with a guy
grabbing my shirt everyone like I swear
to god man that's what goes with it I
like that it was it was bad it was bad
until I turned 14 then like I saw
playing with all the kids in the chain
but before that mm-hmm what do you think
about Kentucky's 2025 right now Brandon
Bostian 10 are really excited for all
you saw
yeah Mineski oh yeah so everybody I mean
everybody's tough in that class
I think for them is who's is you gotta
buy into the system of being the same
worried about individual success at
first because once you win games I mean
everybody everybody stepping away that's
why you don't want to play get people
man now he makes me just as mad I will
say people's like
where I don't know why but I just get so
mad me to tell you I'm very competitive
on feet then I get hot sometimes the
word is gold my control dog like I turn
the game off mic I mean wanna play I
will rage quit on feet for all the time
but that's where the reason why I don't
play ultimate team though because
ultimately our killers bro Ultimate Team
mode that sided up for stress because of
the place that you need to peek and then
instead we gonna play soon games you
probably honest you played on my thing
there's always like management I mean
it's just hard to stop
I mean you know what he's doing but it's
still hard to stop so I mean definitely
find one again Superman just competing
like the first hand maybe is about like
40 then that last we're in the game I
mean just seeing them get better every
time I play and this is just fun
how can you stop Yanis what's the
biggest keep trying stuff yeah I don't
think you can stop him I think you could
containment though I mean it's
definitely hard Otis I mean he's about 7
foot arms long and then as soon as he
gets in the pain he's just gonna spin
move it just go straight left other dog
every time so I mean there's nobody
really blocking him or anything so you
got to be physical with him and just try
to contain yeah
that's what I call that I saw that a
single lifestyle from the TV if you wake
up we're gonna say you picture you can
picture PlayStation over over over women
a lot of time put me trouble into this
[Music]
[Laughter]
the CMM as PJ how can you tell the
difference between Cody and Caleb mark
shout out to the Marne swing they act
different and then they're cut they kind
of look different you guys really like
Hey look like his forehead small-engine
cubbies and Cody's nose like more pointy
- Kaylee so that's why I had to change
the interview them while they were in
cars and all the way I could sell the
difference because one had a different
braids style than the other one and so
he was like okay
as long as I remember to pray stop what
is it like watching the last dance after
getting back to buy a bit oh no I
haven't watched the excuse I've been
watching it hoes are
[Music]